yeah there could be improvements to the
YouTube algorithm but it's still better
than the the twitch algorithm which
doesn't really have an algorithm at
least in terms of discovery okay um
let's play e5
I'll stick with something classical and
normal played a lot of this this opening
yesterday actually I ran into castling
yesterday
interesting move hey congratulations oh
you can see oh so that means your hair
was probably obstructing your vision
what's the move here played d6 I usually
like to play a 6 Bishop a7 before
castling because there's cases where
white plays Bishop g5 like here where
then I don't need to Castle kingside
basically I'm questioning the bishop and
then I'm probably happy to play g5
thanks for subbing over key mistakes
gifting another sub gifting the 25th sub
to the the channel thanks so much so I'm
I'm calculating G 5 9 th d 5 if I can
get away with this
like if G 5 digit e3 I'll be happy but
just trying to make sure that I'm not
running into issues the very worst I
have rook probably rook g8 is good
enough there's h4 and then what can come
to g6 in the event of Queen f3 I'll play
g5 so going back to why I played a6
instead of casting is now it's very
possible I very likely I have more
castle and the King will either stay in
the center or eventually Castle
queenside I'm assuming this will be
played
yeah working with six gifting a sub -
Nathan lo 99 Nathan lo is I think one of
the first in the chat thanks again to
the rookie so the move I'd like to play
is is Knight h5 there's a few ideas here
there's g4g four looks nice to the g4
takes takes then there's ninety four
ideas
I mean c3 would be likely there but then
the g5 will open and B rook g8 I can
also be be patient also realizing night
here sometimes I'd have to like be
worried about tactics but if I play that
h5 and I takes e5 Knight takes g3 f7 I
don't want to calculate that it could be
okay but I think I'll start with this
I'm actually curious if we're following
like some sort of lying or theory or
something that's been played before also
hello to everyone else this is not a
London for black even though like this
sort of setup maybe resembles a London
flipped and reversed but this is an
Italian opening so it's a bit different
but it's very often you'll see this kind
of harmony with the bishop developed
outside the pawn chain and yeah the
black pieces are coordinating well very
much looking forward to some kind of
King side attack still theory
yeah theory never ends at least that's
the theory according to some people okay
so yeah I'll take develop the bishop all
minor pieces developed there's two pins
in this position
the Knights pin but also that pawns pin
which means this bishops not defended
which means it's very likely I'll go for
some kind of Knight h5 yeah ninety-two
is also possible and so now they try was
very consistent with my my plans and
then I think white would be likely
either to play Bishop h4 Bishop h2 I was
just calculating Queen digs h4 90 x h4
it's a big trade
I have 93 in that and but okay I thought
there were could take
not sure how good that is so if not h5
Bishop h4 I probably play Queen d7 and
then it's still still looking fun Bishop
each three ideas and same applies with
Bishop h2 and I'm gonna have this move
most likely this move also this move
possibility I have to invite all my
pieces to the party so Bishop h4 yeah
just double checking the sign it's
really just a big trade
if the night weren't here I'd have this
but the problem with Bishop takes on
three is a knight takes off three I'll
play Queen d7 hey Brian how's it going
welcome back
yeah if you're just joining this is the
first game of the stream this is the one
of the tournament's organized by fee day
I think for for the duration of this
month every hour of every day there's
some kind of feed a tournament as part
of the series now I do have to be
cognizant there's no increment even
though this feels like slow chess I
can't get too too ignorant so white on
pins the night
it's not a happy square for the Queen
though I actually don't know even though
the lights unpinned planet wants to draw
it's funny even though they like some
pins you can't really move anywhere
great so I think I'll just continue with
the game plan
just keep improving
and why it's really tighten down like
this bishop can't move the bishop g3i I
have this with the pin the knight can
move because tied down to other night
because there's a potential pin along
the G file I'm threatening this
there's not even 91 because the Queen's
in the way so White's pieces are kind of
tied down to each other and stumbling on
top of each other while hacker I'm
trying to go but I'm also trying to stay
here thanks for subbing for three months
with prime so King eh - that's it's
probably a decent move for this
situation yeah
it stopped my plan
if I had the chance I'd like to come
inside castle but that's not not
possible
there's a few things I'm considering I
mean this is one of the most forcing
lines idea after it takes takes Queen G
fourth running mate
94 can be a potential threat there for
example it takes takes Queen G for
Ritchie 194 just trying to drive away
this night so if Knight takes before I'm
8
and if pawn takes I have an eye that for
threatening Queen eh we mate which looks
unstoppable so okay this is for saying
what else can like play I guess Bishop
XIII
there's mg 3s would have really only
move then the line keeps going there's
93 plunging III Queen h5 net h4 the
queen is actually useful defending the
g3 fallen one more time takes takes
Queen g4 Bishop z3 I don't have to take
immediately well I appreciate you too
it looks very nice I could probably just
chill in that position it seems a bit
committal giving away my LightSquared
bishop but if I chase the bishop back
it's kind of stuck just staring at my
pawn chain like Queens like hassle could
probably play metaphor there because the
bishop would be pinned to the the g2
pawn dozen either for have a threat
before probably threatens Queen h5 kim
ji-won wrote g3 because of the pin again
couple that with this also cal saying
doubling up the rooks looks nice
and that's like the best case scenario
for white too unless I miss something
sometimes this will happen where I'll go
so deep down the wormhole that I'll
forget that there is like another
another path just right next to the
wormhole so sometimes you have to
balance between depth and width or
breadth I don't know what the right word
is maybe check and help me
okay so queen g4 I'm happy here
pieces are are talking to each other
breath yeah
yeah it's a very big theme in like when
calculating in chess where yeah you can
think maybe five moves ahead but then
you have to look at like a bunch of
different branches too and then good
players kind of have a I think sometimes
have a better intuitive sense of what
branches are more relevant and what
lines deserve more attention and a lot
of that comes with experience
open Nana Brad mmm maybe that's uh no if
that was the food I was looking for
always down from banana bread so rook g1
so this is one of the lines I was
looking at and I just assumed this move
right yeah 94 yeah because the lights
tied down if not moves anywhere I just
basically meet the pitch of g3 I I take
at the very least I went up on
I'm looking for something more in that
line it seems very close to me I mean I
could just take steaks takes like
literally takes takes takes takes takes
with check and then keep taking stuff so
there's a lot of ways to win this um
again I just want to be precise and not
give my opponent any mercy I am looking
for meeting ideas I mean probably just
this is a simplest approach yeah this is
completely winning sooner this let's go
for this yeah so things are falling in
the end I'll still have a pretty
significant attack - thanks for subbing
also thanks yeah thanks everyone I think
maybe there are some subs I missed gore
dilly and wall hacker 88 and CWF 30 all
solving with prime thanks so much
so I could take the rook I mean honestly
this Bishop is like as strong as the
rook I'm considering this
rook f1 yeah let's just take our rook
with Chuck and naväge something a tier 1
4 4 3 months thanks everyone
okay so the attack has been a success
I'm up the exchange and the pawn and
still have an attack I think it's more
common that attacks usually don't end in
mate but end in like winning material in
some way just transpired to other end
games I guess yeah King h2 has only
moved there to prevent rook g3 now
Ritchie 5 threatening meaning to now
this attack is probably ending in meat
have I been watching any pause champs
I've seen some of the clips I don't
think I'd like watched a full show been
a bit busy but it's been interesting
content it's not the typical like
serious chess tournament that's
interesting to watch for sure
Don silver thanks for subbing for three
months yet which subs at least Tier one
and prime subs are split 50-50 between
twitch and the content creator
I think tier two sums are split 6040 and
Tier three is 70/30 but if you have
twitch prime it's basically basically
free so it's basically just donating 250
on the monthly basis
yeah white suffering and pain crying in
agony
sobbing and sorrow I should write a
thesaurus
to be fair like twitch does have a lot
of like server costs and they do I
visited their headquarters in in San
Francisco and it's very impressive space
like they have all these streaming rooms
and as ping-pong table one ping pong
yeah one ping pong table a few fuse ball
tables yeah it's gonna try this but it's
still still crushing mmm I could show a
picture I don't think it's against
twitch yet stuffing that against any
Terms of Service to show twitch HQ ice
cream from twitch HQ
anyway thanks for the game uh-huh I've
got a little bit off-topic thanks for
the game chess 1865 probably not my
opponent's birthday may be my opponent
raining I don't know yeah I'm curious
like what the theory is I'm pretty sure
Bishop g5 is not a great move may be
playable but I'm check the mass use a
base the in general White's like when my
plays Italian white delays developing
the bishop and goes for stuff like this
this eventually Knights here here
sometimes a the Queen side expansion
sometimes eventually d4 may probably
Bishop g5 playable once I've committed
to castling he had no no master player
has played Bishop g5 in this position
again this is already yeah is briefly
like how hitting this but blacks doing
quite well here because of a piece and
has some attacking potential
and then this is just a fun position
anyway hopefully people can learn
something from that game maybe I'll put
that on YouTube despite some of the
off-topic topics oh I was gonna show a
picture foosball at twitch HQ with
strong players yeah so this is where the
some of the sub money goes it's a fun
the the foosball table I'm not very good
at foosball this was - Manos was a beast
but these guys were pretty good too
anyway YouTube people hope you enjoyed
that I'll see you in the future